hey what is up guys I'm could be HD here
and today we're going to be taking a
look at this we're taking a look at the
oneplus one now you may remember I've
already done a video about the oneplus
one but a lot has changed about the
phone and the company between that video
and now so that's why I'm doing this
revisited video to go over those changes
and what they mean and why you should
care
take a look so I reviewed this phone a
full two months ago right before it
first came out and it turned out to be a
ridiculously good buy you get great
awesome high-end specs for that crazy
low price that was the main focus even
cheaper than a nexus it started at $300
but then the big question was would
CyanogenMod update this phone like a
nexus i mean it was basically a signage
and mod phone it runs the custom
CyanogenMod 11s operating system and i
had a few bugs that have talked about in
the initial review not gonna lie they're
pretty disappointing but it was a
question mark whether they'd fixed them
or not so here we are two months later
and it turns out yeah these guys have
been vigilant with squashing bugs and
improving the performance of the
software every week this thing exists so
I've gotten several software updates in
the time since I've first got it the
first of which pretty much cured all the
major bugs I talked about the full
review and as subsequent updates have
further improved performance bringing it
to the smoothness level of a nexus or a
Google Play edition device and for those
of us who have used CyanogenMod before
it's usually pretty fast but for some
reason it never quite reaches or matches
the stock Android experience like you
get on a nexus but impressively enough
they've actually done that with the
oneplus one it's really smooth now so
performance is fast and all the bugs and
issues I had before are gone and it's
even added some features so one of the
biggest improvements I like here and the
building up is the themes store there
are a ton more themes than when I first
got this phone there was just a couple
and you can make your phone look like
basically anything you want from an LG
g3 to a samsung galaxy s5 to Android L
or anything in between you can make a
crazy hybrid Frankenstein OS and all
these themes are built into one big
showcase or a catalog which is pretty
impressive to look at and another thing
I noticed that got a lot more sensitive
is
screen off gestures as they are more and
more getting activated in my pocket that
there's a double tap gesture to turn the
screen on that you know activated in my
pocket once in a while but the funny
thing is the torch which can get
accidentally activated just by drawing
the shape of the V on the screen when
it's off that got activated in my pocket
all the time like sometimes I pull my
phone on my pocket wondering how did it
get so warm and it's because it was
sitting in my pocket with the LED light
on killing battery so I have to turn
those features off but you know at least
you can turn them off that's I guess the
beauty of CyanogenMod is those features
can be activated or deactivated and on
top of that this version of CyanogenMod
11's is built on top of Android 4.4
KitKat now oneplus has promised that
within 90 days of the final release of
Android L this phone will be updated to
that too so now that all these software
fixes and changes have been made and
it's obvious that CyanogenMod cares a
lot about keeping this phone up to date
this shift has focused to the hardware
side of things and the company side of
things which is kind of a logistical
nightmare right now but it's just being
able to buy this phone you may have
heard there is an invite-only system
still all these months later and
invite-only system to be able to get
your hands on this phone and even so
it's kind of hard to get an invite and
people are scouring the internet for
invites everywhere and I also saw a
tweet from my buddy Quinn from snazzy
labs where he actually got an invite
placed his order and then was able to
follow the process and when he placed
his order his phone had not even started
manufacturing yet he got a phone fresh
off the assembly line basically when his
order was completed and shipped to him
that's how tight they are for making
these phones for orders they've also
shifted their focus to making the 64 gig
black version since it apparently was
getting more demand than the 16 gig
white one and that actually doesn't
surprise me much given the value but
they've also had some issues with people
reporting as sort of a yellowing of
their oneplus one screen near the bottom
I haven't had any such issues with mine
in fact I noted the color temperature
looked a little warm anyway but that's
not a manufacturing defect it's just a
different panel but the thing is if they
do ship out a phone with the defect and
someone wants to return it for a
replacement they don't have any
replacements so yeah it comes down to
the scarce availability of this phone
it's a new comp
me with a great product high demand low
supply I guess it's a good problem to
have that you have so many orders that
you can't even really keep up with
everyone who's trying to buy these
things but at the same time that's kind
of annoying for a lot of people who
really don't like not being able to buy
this device and will eventually lose
interest and move on to buy other things
anyway so of course there's all sorts of
parodies and things like that but so
yeah there's the the high end and the
low end of this revisited it's the high
end that yeah it turns out they really
do care about updating a software and
they're going to keep it up to date and
it's made a lot of progress and they
fixed tons of bugs and then there's the
low end where it's still kind of hard to
get this unicorn phone and hopefully
you'll be able to get an invite if you
really do want one spoiler alert
I do have invites in fact I have a
hundred of them and I'm going to be
giving them away on Twitter sometime in
the next two days or so so definitely
follow their if you want to be in on
that yeah but that's about it let me
know what you guys think of the oneplus
one in this revisited and I'll talk to
you guys in the very next video
bass